hey Matt got your email with the report
thanks so much for sending question did
you see see John on that uh yes I
believe I did oh that's interesting cuz
I'm looking at that email right now and
he didn't owe you BC CB oh you still got
the email then right I did look I know
you're new around here so I just want to
make sure that you understand the email
protocol
you always CC both John and I on all
work emails is if you BCC him then I
can't check to make sure that you see
see them got it I made a mistake great
question
why did you make that mistake um I guess
I'm a little tired this morning oh my
gosh why are you so tired I am anxiety
that sometimes keeps me up at night what
causes this anxiety I guess sometimes I
feel like this can be sort of a
confrontational work environment okay
but Hampton de Ville encourages
aggressive confrontational criticism why
don't you like confrontation defend your
position oh no I mean I think
confrontation is a good thing it's just
sometimes confrontation hurts my job
performance and damages my personal
well-being oh well if you can't manage
your emotions Matt what makes you think
you're qualified to manage people at
this company honestly I don't know oh I
never really saw myself here
I mean after college I volunteered for a
program teaching underprivileged kids
because I wanted to help people but then
one of the students stabbed me and the
school was pretty dirty and I realized I
wasn't cut out for it so I moved back in
with my parents which I'm pretty sure
led to them getting a divorce because
that's what they told me happened then I
worked a series of jobs it eventually
landed me here or I'm just a cog in a
soulless corporate machine and I'm not
well just make sure that you see see
both John and I on all work emails it's
a simple mistake but it's just important
to follow protocol yes
Jake question why do you think it's okay
to come into work with your shirt
untucked
because life is meaningless and nothing
we do matters okay great
have a great day thanks guys
[Music]
hamton de Ville has emerged as one of
the largest most profitable corporations
in the world
with over 300,000 employees
internationally their footprint
stretches across the globe under the
leadership of their CEO Christian de
ville
they've become market leaders in
everything from agricultural goods to
pharmaceuticals from household
appliances to industrial weaponry you've
probably heard their slogan Hamden de
Ville we make everything but now they
are attempting to muscle their way
marks the launch of the obelisk Hampton
de Vil's touchscreen tablet which boasts
screen eight times the size of the iPad
but that launch may be in jeopardy
after an insensitive tweet was sent out
from Hampton de Vil's Twitter account
earlier today as hurricane Leticia
continues to devastate the Gulf Coast
Hampton de vil tweeted was your house
blown away by hurricane Leticia pick up
the obelisk to follow hurricane news
you'll be blown away by the size in
response to the offensive tweet the
Internet is calling for a boycott of the
[Music]
do you think we're gonna get to eat
anything today don't count on it there's
a rigid food hierarchy here executives
get first pick in junior executives than
us the junior executives in training 500
billion dollar corporation and they
never have enough bagels for everyone
why didn't you eat breakfast before 1:00
I didn't have time I hit the snooze
button 15 times this morning which is a
new record that I'm actually kind of
proud of did you eat anything no I'm
trying to watch my figure I want to have
a hot body cuz I'm tired of developing
my personality yeah I've been there Yama
I love eclairs my god this is so good
I'm gonna take two aggressive confident
I like that you're not afraid to take
what you want hmm
damn it there's only two bagels left
whoa have you seen this tweet the
company sent out the Internet is
freaking out about it
you'll be blown away by the size Jesus
Christ with an inside of a nightmare why
is everyone standing around eating
bagels while we're being crucified on
the Internet
spit out those bagels we're work to do
sorry everyone in this room look to your
left now look to your right 100% of
those people are ruining my day look
that one over there still good I'm gonna
get it after the meeting yeah but
there's no cream cheese all over there
into developing the Ovilus and now it's
success is being threatened by tweet
I wish I could be more like Christian
look at my business my anyone
psycho-pass Stanford exactly he fought
his way to the top and now we get to
treat people like there was personal
service dogs my fiber get to the job
done at least make sure everyone gets a
goddamn bagel don't worry you'll be
corrupted by power that's part of
growing up I want to tell you a story
[Music]